I've got some footage on assure you yeah
check this out okay so we're in say a
college in America somewhere high school
I mean that was supposed to be a that
was I mean just when you're making a
highlight reel don't include the
walkouts it's not worth it like the
handshakes leave that in literally ugh
shooting goddamn it if I was a fighter I
think I'd be like a submission your
heart pinned down in arguments exactly
and I just slowly choke you out it's
verbal jujitsu is what Lawrence is an
expert has you got it yeah yeah this is
oh that must be horrible no you know
what you don't understand this how
flexible these guys are well it's
incredible I mean literally they could
let her last his off so while chewing
this tour Neil I'm assuming that's
offensive
and there's the submission I'm gonna be
honest with you Bryan this guy has just
been called out by Jake Paul let's go
this guy Jake Paul wants a piece wants a
piece of that ass in the Octagon not in
a boxing ring so the thing is he is
Conor McGregor's trainin partner Jake
Paul thinks he can beat him it turns out
Shane you need to go back for another
episode you this guys [__] crazy to
be honest with you I sort of see the
logic a little bit a little bit so we
start this episode by looking at the
definition of [__] we'll call the
psychologist for an hour and see what a
[__] is he thought you had a fight okay
so this guy's big enough that Joe
Rogan's reacting yeah yeah he's a [__]
taught us right the world laws welcome
and he's he's adopted the Conor McGregor
way of talk in the confidence to Aragon
so you see him getting clipped the long
wait he's getting put he's not clipped
he could have been knocked out there to
be fair so on the feet
that's not his speciality he's a
submission guy as you say but because he
trains with Conor McGregor and he likes
in all the big Conor McGregor events
ways promoting proper twelve or when the
boss thing happened I think he was maybe
in there he's just around McGregor so
you know he is he's his name in the mmmm
a lot bigger than it should be right
because he's about that friendship and I
think because of that Jake's looking at
him like a perfect guy to fight to have
some credibility publicity yeah you got
the big name and everyone knows him yet
he isn't an expert on the field
that being said Jake's probably seen
about a minute as we have there of him
fighting on the on the feet he looked
bad against another striker another MMA
fighter that doesn't mean that you're
able to step in the ring with them yeah
so what do you think the logic of Jake
Paul is because it can't just be this
I'm in this fight to win for Jake he
gets in a ring with a professional MMA
fighter with a crash near him if he
doesn't lose in the first few rounds he
gets massive credibility father in the
balls but legitimise if you wins then
Dillon Dallas is humiliated from a
business standpoint
Jake's thinking [__] me this is great
this is brilliant you can't call me a
[__] if I step in the ring with this
guide do you ever think let's just test
it one more time in another youtuber
Jessica ugly and so because I don't know
offense the Deji but desi and Dillon
diners are very different shape people
different X trees like Dillon's honest
for all he looked bad on the feet there
he's training with Conor McGregor every
[__] day yeah like he's gonna gnaw
some [__] he might have just had a bad
fight he might be better than what that
Shawn and he may get in there and punch
the [__] out of you in about two minutes
there's a very real possibility I saw
the guy is probably a better strike
strike her as well vanilla near as the
guys probably about a strike other than
dead G no offense the dead she wasn't
that he's got some natural ability
deadly but he's a lot smaller than Jill
Adonis there's a totally different
[__] fight do you think there's a
problem here is that Jay Paul's fights
only people with D in their name that
literally is like Daniel a G Derek
Acorah Derek Acorah and Derek Derek's
busy even dead she took Jake of good few
rounds
Jake's been getting a lot of [__] from
the MMA crowd because it's like yeah
you're a [__] [__] or this year that
I think no he's just offered to fight an
MMA fight around yeah there's nothing
[__] about Jake Paul from doing one you
got to give the Lord credit and I admire
these balls but I'm just thinking just
make sure you're [__] ready for this
show after every Dillon darkness
Instagram post Jake's post no Nate I
would beat your ass like I actually
really admire the balls on them I admire
it I love your balls because he's
baiting him but surely you do not want
to
this guy angry if you want to get don't
worry because I think for Dylan he must
be thinking if I step in there and don't
wipe him out in around my reputation as
this MMA hard man is in tunnel knows
he's taught mad [__] about John George
like real bad men Jeremy who would
probably kill him but if you're
challenging anyone cuz this guy's
clearly not a boxer he's a you know he's
someone who likes to get him down and
submit them if you need to consult
anyone Jake can call his trainer right
Dylan Danis yeah Connor
yet remember when you fought one of the
greatest boxers of all time yeah yeah
could you pass that on to me you'll come
down next week and train for two weeks
with me cuz you got very little on right
now
fantastic friend yeah look if I friend
that's what I'm saying you know me
Jake's got Shawn in the cannon Briggs to
follow you've gotta ask yourself this
question Brian would you rather have the
phone number of Shannon Briggs or you
yourself Conor McGregor
I don't you need that the phone number
of Shannon Briggs just one sort of
recorded answer machine message right
let's go Chum let's go let's go Chum got
beef on YouTube on YouTube never never
do you remember that girl who apparently
got kidnapped and then everyone was like
oh my god where is she and she started
getting loads of views and Khan was
giddy with doubt and she offered the
[__] well er apparently at Jared she was
one of the first women that well I
turned out but anyway the point is him
sort of being calling her out apparently
a little bit and then I think Jack said
something about it in this podcast and
then it sort of spiraled so that's just
theme stars at there cares how he's yeah
he's a massive balance you know much
became Stan not really I know he's quite
mean alright so basically they're
talking [__] about Kim right they don't
really Kim so Kim made a video on
Twitter responding to chuck it does feel
like - [__] poppin heavyweights mmm
coming head they're good at grappling
they're good at strike they're basically
all these guys are heavyweights like you
say so they are yeah yeah nothing wrong
with that be on Twitter maybe you should
have talked [__] about anyone cuz you
can't take it and by the way during that
pot
three you're talking [__] this creature
that is not fair creature as a funny
word this uses proper name which is be
Millis plus one ksi coined that and
that's a fair I've hated that person
since he's never shown his face on this
goddamn platform you two are pathetic
and sad I must admit right I think he
was actually talking to my son I admit
maybe it was what I liked about Jack and
Kim and it's not they don't mince their
words like they do just come out and be
like I either [__] like someone I
[__] hear them so in the moment they
say whatever that yeah and and the thing
is when it comes to a part of which I'd
put Chuck me up against anyone he's
funny as [__] but when it comes to just
straight-up talk and [__] Kim's got a
black belt in that came for a tweet out
afterwards saying you've got the frosted
tip that was quite funny nice funny but
I always say that because I'm like you
me weed not lot not a lot of him I like
Jack's hair though ever thought of
frosting your tips crossed yourself why
would I do that that's that's a
reference to How to Lose a Guy in 10
days frost yourself being a Matthew
McConaughey Upton is there how you like
to see me take my shirt off do you ever
think there is a problem in that when
you podcast you feel like you are in a
private little place you feel you can
have a chat I've stood laughing well I
revealed what Logan said to me in a text
message and then all of a sudden it's on
drama alert yeah he goes on to say that
he spoke to Logan and Logan said it's
all lies I don't think I'm Alex said he
was friends with him any point that keen
was so he was do minim sort of thing if
this fits into my whole life I've hated
this person since the day got on this
platforms beacon of beef I got involved
in a little bit of a Twitter but knew it
with William formerly of xo5 I've kicked
them out now what happened so basically
I put a picture up of my video me last
one with the whiteboard in the
background saying what should I paint
here and he said I dog you it's the
shirt that needs changing all of his sub
part intellect basic [__] funds have
come out and supporting him for that
that's so funny
haha sorry it's not a [__] hoodie
with no collar on ya with a word on it
fashionista Ryan and I are starting a
label called Spade he then come out and
said oh sorry mister Giacomo just
because they don't come in sizes for
Giants
body shaming don't get caught up in this
sideline let's not forget that that is
basically body shaming yeah that's body
shaming a fat person who eats his
emotions you don't talk to Brian my
buddy's hot half an hour time I looked
at the likes obviously I make a mental
note of them all yeah so many girls yeah
liking this and I'm like oh sorry if any
of you lot got called fatty I'm sure
that you wouldn't think it was that
funny double standard double eight well
you love double a double cream yep
double chocolate yeah double chocolate
double cheeseburger Mike Norvell can
slugs look it's disgusting body they
shout talking about why I saved my first
kiss for marriage so actually as y'all
are watching this video right now I will
be on my honeymoon she's gonna be yes we
all know where you're going with this
she hasn't had any kisses she's never
kissed a man she's not even you know
what dick I have not kissed Dave we are
saving our first kiss for when we are
husband and wife and that may be so
weird to some of you all you might be
like I have never heard of that
imagine having to listen to this [__]
for like months I'm calling your a [__]
just waiting to [__] up is wrong with
what kind of loser would do that she's
about to be as coordinated as a [__]
horse on roller skates in bed can I just
say that sounds like a great YouTube
series what if we did something so
radical what if we waited until we are
husband and wife
to actually cannot occur is when you
overthrow the government paper or
plastic a month we should save sex for
marriage an intimacy ultimately is
reserved for marriage but not breathe at
all I'm gonna not breathe until I'm
married how about we wait until we're
married to do anything together we will
not speak that you prefer after
listening to her for two minutes I think
he probably wishes this until marriage
no because damn I couldn't understand
why a good Christian guy we
good Christian values we want to marry a
big as atheist I thought our you know
some bigger atheist than me I'm six foot
but I'm not a big guy can you imagine on
their wedding day
you may kiss the brides oh my god is
amazing she's literally kissing him on
the like nose because I am is so bad how
do we do this again
gays are a lot of really awesome godly
guys out there are amazing there are
also a lot that are just not quite so
awesome it must be hard to find an
awesome godly guy okay you shouldn't
date quarter marry is that Jodi mister
talk mister talk is also known as mr.
smooth what you want to find is an
awkward guy who stutters over every word
the second you find that guy marry that
godly son-of-a-bitch Louis Theroux I say
Marisa I was just wondering I was
thinking about a date last week is that
something we could do and she goes my
god he's he's [__] godly he's awesome
oddly calm so for example he might say
yeah I love the Lord I love going to
church
I love getting involved I love reading
my Bible that she's suckin this guy's
dick she's not sorry he's like look I'm
a really awesome godly guy and if you
suck my dick like I'm up for doing any
of the churchy stuff that you want to do
to me so she literally sucks a fat Lord
out and then afterwards I start our God
would have really been proud of you then
he would have loved that and she's like
she's like okay so now we can read Bible
and he goes I'm just gonna get I'm just
gonna get half an hour I'm retired from
work but you read your Bible and then
tell me about it after well can you
imagine though being in a relationship
with a girl going here they go you
haven't read your Bible today and I'm
like [__] I'm [__] tired man do you
know let me worry about your own [__]
Bible reading I'll worry about mine
we've been reading the Bible now for
five years can we use another book
alright and at any wall and the Bible
starts [__] making us money then
we'll talk but I've got bills to pay
woman if in the first seven days God had
created a Bosch Auto dryer I believe
he would have put the instructional in
the New Testament okay I imagine her
husband has another book inside the
Bible do you know reading the Bible I'm
reading the Bible I'm still reading the
Bible but a spite about coming Bruce
Wayne really inspires me when you say
Bruce Wayne do you mean Moses I met
Moses guy number two is mr. anger this
is the guy that gets like set off by
really small things driving in a car and
someone just barely comes in his other
Lane and he gets flipped blows up and
gets really mad it's like I've been in a
car we have control of his temper does
not have control over his tongue in his
mouth and what do you think woman you'll
miss an out I personally would never
date or marry a mr. anger and I would
encourage you not to either
I like how they think they're so perfect
yeah that's what's really becoming
apparent the way they're like this is
who I don't want this isn't you know who
I don't want mrs. religion ah this is
religion is fine it's just it's mrs.
sanctimonious that I'm worried about do
you know that man it's just always
struggling but always telling you that
he's gonna do better that he's gonna get
over it
so we highly caution you with a guy
that's really struggling because if
there's one thing religion teaches us
it's to not help anyone who's struggling
we do often hear like oh lust it's a guy
problem sexual but the reality is it's
not a guy problem it's a human problem
can I just say you and I have
conversations on a daily basis about
listen perfectly healthy things come
along and I say Brian you have a good
night last night you say yeah just
stayed in I played a little Red Dead
Redemption
I had a nice evening to myself I got a
little take away there's no sex
mentioned sometimes sometimes we can go
literally minutes without talking about
sex these people speak so much about sex
scratch the itch girls just scrub no I'm
not saying that I'm just saying stop
talking about it and it will not bother
you anymore
not true because every time they just
and just graze against their [__]
they're like stop if I really had a good
corner I tell you what I put money on
that these two I've had a good [__] a
flicker they're beans they think I'm
this perfect Christian girl if I speak
up what's gonna happen to my reputation
to my friends one of my parents gonna
think tell your family about all your
sexual mom there's something to share
against but for one the doom I'm
struggling with sexual obsession and sin
again mom all of those cooking and
sausage casserole and all of a sudden
just cutting the sausage in law we've
got to get this out of our heads bethany
and david engagement story i need to say
this kid i need come on David he's
drugged him sinners sinners wash them
clean they touch a lot of them you can
tell this so frustrating score now
there's no way you can touch each other
as much as they are and not go forward
and just go for the full thing what's
happening with the hands like their
hands are [__] because they can't oh
my god oh he got the guitar
[Music]
it's bad this is what she's been waiting
for this is what she's slugging everyone
else because this is the pinnacle these
kind of people go to Ed Sheeran concerts
and enjoy it she thought Greece wasn't
even a musical she thought it was a
documentary I thinks he's so smooth
doesn't he yeah he's a mr. smooth I'm
gonna blow his beans in her muff she's
gonna waited for this for 30 [__]
miserable years to get [__] by that
little geek for 30 [__] seconds well
done
one second per [__] year you've been
bored you know now get our butter even
that [__] Bible she's gonna have to
endure at least a 40-minute ukulele
session that night I can't believe we're
married we're still married now I'm
looking at your body and you're still
married to me they don't even rhyme
David this has been sent to me and I've
been told that guys yeah oh yeah but
come on in are you gonna come in welcome
will we're ending it with we'll leave
the bus fella this is food reviewer
doing King fillets spicy chicken Sam
I've been told this is classic food
review and you never knew such a cool
dude I keep it so flat and do you know
why it's because I know whether to buy
dad food today we're in Warwick Rhode
Island Warwick he wouldn't fit one of
the shuttle shirts either there's just
no knuckles there is there they're just
some good so I'll come chick-fil-a I
just feel so comfortable right now
genuinely when he's ordering fast food
is probably the only time he ever told
you he's got a really feminine looking
fit like he reminds me of like a grandma
who hands out
sloppy jaws at our high school lunch
either a pulling away
she's not even stopped he's ready he's
an expert drive-thru man oh yeah I mean
he knows when this is done oh yeah look
how happy is his face
look at his eye I love him look at the
way is he just such a nice guys Lawrence
all he's doing is collecting food oh
it's the awkward demeanor it's like that
he's got a slightly guilt you know on
his face like I was once up behind my
dad and a drive through my dad is miles
behind him and you know the bollards
that they have next to the drive-thru he
literally scraped his car all the way
along one of those bollards and I was
just like yes the man who gives me life
yeah fantastic
Brian else I followed on and scraped
across - oh yeah you've got another look
it never says anything I never was the
minimum to bite if not three bites
before a reaction I would love to meet
this guy I really want to meet him he's
actually being talked about getting us a
flight to America can you imagine us
daily drive through with him I seized on
that might be a tear in his eye from
loves a [__] stick of butter let's go
do you know he reminds me of you know
Willy Wonka with the German kid comes
yeah hit this again like it's a
struggler wasn't it it is drugs for him
and it will kill him one day yo Dee Don
juice on flapjacks cookie how much was
this cookie 135
that is so cheap cookie this big you go
to McDonald's and you get I can't even
believe how good to stuff it and this is
this is fast food it is my taste buds
are like am I at like a [__]
five-star restaurant so trick fly spicy
chicken sandwich is definitely a by
waffle fries of I cook you by I'm sure I
already said it if you are a chick-fil-a
owner you must be looking to be a nice
kid this cat my car yeah 500,000 views
any loved it
so that's that's all we've got time for
for today's video
one thing we are taking part in soon the
Wembley car XO we're gonna be winning a
trophy if you want to come to us lift
that tickets sales in the comments well
if you want to come to Wembley support
the lads get the shirt that's all they
we have something that's legends those
people and real footballers so yeah it
should be good check it out thanks for
watching everyone as soon as they are
chilly I think you've got to see EE
sorry yeah sorry it's the EE when billy
club see you later everyone bye bye